good morning welcome to the fifth annual
vivian pin symposium
i'm janine clayton and i'm delighted to
be here to welcome you to day one of a
fantastic program
i'm going to start by setting the stage
the title of my brief remarks are
integrating sex and gender into
biomedical research as a path for better
science and innovation
i need to begin by expressing
appreciation for
the many women and health care providers
and essential workers who have been
holding it down for all of us for this
last past year
the coba 19 pandemic has certainly
thrown us all for a loop and we're
dedicated we're we're delighted uh to be
here today and i want to begin my
remarks by expressing our appreciation
i also want to begin uh by acknowledging
dr vivian penn and her legacy of
leadership
this symposium is named for dr vivian
penn the first full-time director of the
office of research on women's health an
incredible trailblazer and pioneer
and advocating for women's health and
inclusion of women and underrepresented
groups from the very beginning we want
to acknowledge and thank dr pin for her
amazing contributions and you'll hear
more about her and from her later today
as you know the office of research on
women's health our rwh mission is
three-fold we want to expand women's
health research we want to make sure
that under-represented groups are
included as well as women and we want to
make sure that all women in stem reach
their full potential as we imagine a
world where sex and gender are
integrated across the research continuum
and every woman receives evidence-based
treatment and care designed her for her
own
circumstances needs and goals
and to do that we've worked with the 27
institutes and centers at nih and our
internal and external stakeholders to
develop an nih-wide strategic plan and i
like to say the ultimate goal of the
strategic plan is the first goal which
is to advance rigorous research that is
relevant to the health of women
today we're talking about sex and gender
very important determinants and play a
critical role in all of our health so
just to begin with some definitions sex
is a biological variable determined by
chromosomal complement
gender is a multi-dimensional social
construct with multiple domains
including gendered roles behaviors
expressions gender dynamics gender
identity and both matter in health and
disease
most recently
dr londa schievinger and her colleagues
put forward a new paper that talks about
how to measure gender and puts forward
gender as a social variable
complementary to sex as a biological
variable
you'll hear from dr shivinger later
i'll start now by talking about where we
are and where we need to go
so here's the data
in the united states we have shorter
lives and poorer health than our peer
countries us represented in pink care
women on the left men on the right life
expectancy at birth over the past few
years our life expectancy as birth at
birth has been falling further and
further behind our peer countries
and this paper looked at whether it was
which age group was which at which age
that life expectancy was altered
for other countries it was for illnesses
over the age of 65. for the united
states this shortening of our life
expectancy is related to diseases and
conditions that occur before the age of
65.
drug overdoses and other chronic
conditions were highlighted in this
publication as causes
so i'm going to set the stage and i try
not to
be a negative person i am a quite
optimistic person but i do think we need
to get straight to the point about
what's going on today
first
we see that there's a combination of the
fact that there's this default human
model that's 70 kilogram man and for
founder of use of male animals
in at pre-clinical research that has
resulted in this unidimensional way of
looking at science and that has created
knowledge gaps we just know less about
female biology than we do about male
biology
we see that in various diseases and how
that plays out but most recently a new
publication highlighted the fact that
women actually have less access to the
kidney transplant wait list in the
current era
and black women have even less access to
that wait list
we hear often in the media that women
are not listened to or believed when we
report symptoms of pain or
unused or
non-specific symptoms
many women are not believed and we see
that play out in the maternal morbidity
and mortality crisis in our country
that can result in misdiagnoses and
under treatment
at an institutional level we see that
women's health is not taken as seriously
here's a recent publication that
highlighted that papers on women's
health even though they were judged as
rigorous as papers on men's health were
less likely to get accepted
and cited yet we know that women make 80
of health related decisions in society
and our families and we know that by
improving women's health
especially with pregnant women's health
we can improve everyone's health over
time
and in terms of our investments in
women's health
we see that they're not aligned with our
proportion in the population our central
role as caregivers and decision makers
or consistent with some of our
principles equity principles in good
science
here's one example
so this data shows uh funding related to
specific diseases some diseases
affecting men more than women in blue
some diseases affecting women more than
men in red
in this on the x-axis you see u.s
disability adjusted life years and what
this paper did is they compared the
level of funding
to the
disease burden as defined by disability
adjusted life years
and for that black straight line
represents a one-to-one correspondence
between funding and disability you know
disability-adjusted life years
all of the dots that are above the line
and most of them are blue represent
funding above the level expected and
they're mostly for diseases that affect
more men than women
all the dots below the line and they're
mostly red represents funding that was
less than expected by the disease burden
and they're mostly red reflecting
diseases that are more common in women
than men
so we see a mismatch here
recently the women's health access
matters group or wham has sought change
by quantifying the
economic benefit of women's health
research and i refer to the recent
report
that they did in collaboration with the
rand corporation and they found that
modest investments in women's health
research played out with big impacts in
terms of economic impacts and
improvement of quality of life
in fact they found a return on
investment of 224 percent
just for doubling investments in women's
health research
the multi-dimensional framework
represents an intersection of factors
that affect the health of women and orwh
put this forward in the new nih-wide
strategic plan we have to consider a
life course perspective
all the way from our childhood through
our adulthood the biological perspective
or internal factors in this case first
and foremost sex affect our health as
well as external factors be they social
determinants of health environmental
exposures or even policies
and these internal and external factors
interact over time and across the like
life course to affect the health of
women
the coven 19 pandemic has certainly
demonstrated that sex and gender matter
and we see this excess mortality rate in
men for every 10 women infected there
are 18
icu admissions in men and 15 deaths in
men
but what about
looking at the intersection of sex
gender race and ethnicity and age
this study looked at
coveted mortality rates aged adjusted
mortality rates in georgia and in
michigan
and what they found was
that black women's coven 19 mortality
rates exceeded that of white men's four
times greater than white men three times
greater than asian men and higher than
asian and white women in in
both georgia and michigan
so you can see that it's important to
look at both sex gender race and
ethnicity to be able to have a more
nuanced understanding of what's going on
and to consider local and geographic
environments
these disparities for covenanting
mortality are replicating existing
racial
and health inequities
and while men have a higher rate
than women across
individual racial groups we need to
consider systemic and social factors to
understand how this is playing out in
society
the pandemic has disproportionately
affected women especially women
scientists who are parents we've seen
especially faculty with small children
reporting fewer work hours we've seen
fewer papers being published by women
first or senior authors and we did our
own survey of extramural researchers and
research organizations and supported a
national academy
survey to look at the impact of cobit 19
on the workforce and we're seeing
important effects there
we also are observing a collision of
crises where the maternal mortality
crisis
which was pre-pandemic
women came into this pandemic already
with higher mature mortality rates in
the united states than elsewhere women
of color in particularly affected
and we saw that we need to understand
race
as a social construct not as a medical
risk factor than in and of itself race
is not the risk factor
this is an opportunity to tackle
intransigent disparities in maternal
health
so today what we have is an opportunity
through here's a quote from walter
scheidel
throughout recorded history the most
dramatic and violent ruptures were also
the most effective levelers of social
and economic inequality the collapse of
states the world wars the great
communist revolutions the worst
pandemics belong in the same category
so today we have an opportunity to get
serious about studying sex and gender
the pandemic has exacerbated health
disparities and health inequities it has
revealed ways that sex and gender
influence the health of women it is
affirmed how much we do not know about
conditions and diseases and how they
affect women it is reinforced that women
deserve better it has affirmed just how
important women are to our families our
communities our nation our world and
it's shown that investing in women's
health is the right thing and the smart
thing to do
we do that by moving beyond inclusion
and integrating sex and gender across
the biomedical research continuum from
pre-clinical to translational and
clinical work and integrating sex and
gender into our reporting our education
and our policy
it's now my pleasure to introduce dr
maria freire
dr freya has been an active member of
many international boards and committees
and she comes to us today as the
president and executive director of the
foundation for nih she has received
numerous awards and is
serving on many committees too many to
list here
and i am delighted to have her here and
to be her partner on this effort
you could say like the famous line from
the movie casablanca maria i think this
is the beginning of a beautiful
friendship between orwh and fnih it's my
pleasure to now introduce dr maria freyr
can you thank you for this introduction
uh and thank you for setting for setting
the stage this is
a truly important topic and something
that we're all keenly interested so good
morning everybody i want to
extend my warm welcome along with
jeanine's to all of you who are joining
us for the fifth annual vivienne pin
symposium the fnih is deeply honored to
co-host this event with the nih's office
of research on women's health
as janine says janine this is the
beginning of a great friendship
now i would like to especially thank the
orwh and the steering committee for
convening such an impressive group of
thought leaders
the kind of leaders who i know
will roll up their sleeves and do
impactful work to tackle some of the
challenges that janine just has put
before us
and yes of course there's much work to
be done as the title of the symposium
states
integrating sex and gender into
biomedical research is certainly a
critical endeavor
now in an interesting confluence of
thought
as the fnih itself is celebrating its
25th anniversary this year and i know
janine you celebrated your 30th
anniversary so we're we're pretty much
uh came along at the same time
well our anniversary theme is science
leads
and it parallels very nicely with the
overarching message of this symposium
that science focused on women's health
will result in better outcomes for
everyone
now science leads has been the rallying
cry of the woman we honor today dr
vivienne pin
vivian is a force and an inspiration to
us
she saw the issues related to women's
health and their importance in the
scientific and medical ecosystem
way before many others did so in fact
and if i have to be perfectly honest it
was not an understanding that came
naturally to many now i think that in
fact may be an understatement
but vivian knew that scientific research
is near
neither fully accurate nor effective
unless it considers the entire spectrum
of possibility
vivian recognized the challenges and of
course she recognized the enormous
untapped opportunity that would open
before us once the basic biology
resulting from sex differences would be
understood
the catalytic importance of this
understanding as janine just
went through all the data
but the
the importance of understanding this for
the prevention diagnosis and treatment
of disease cannot be underestimated and
it certainly cannot be overemphasized
it spans the gamut from alzheimer's to
heart disease to covet as we've just
heard
now many of you know dr pinn's
exceptional professional journey
prior to becoming the first full-time
director of the office of research of
women health 30 years ago much of it was
blazing trails and serving as role model
for countless aspiring physicians and
researchers and she continues to do that
today
but what many may not know is at well
apart from my enormous admiration for
her work and our personal friendship
vivian and i share one interesting
common route
we both graduated from the university of
virginia
in fact i spent six years getting my phd
and my first postdoc at jordan hall the
most important medical research building
on campus
so not too long ago i was asked to come
back
and give a lecture at uva
to my absolute delight and surprise
jordan hall is now pin hall in
recognition of one of uva's most
distinguished alumni
such a world deserved honor for an
amazing and classy woman
vivian i do not know how it feels like
to have a whole building named after you
but what a well deserved and wonderful
honor
so yes as janine has put before us there
is much work that still needs to be done
on women's health
but let us not forget where we came from
and the enormous strides that have been
made and upon which
we continue to build and a lot of them
started with vivian's vision
in the next two days the vital
exploration around integrating sex and
gender into biomedical research
promises to create new initiatives build
new partnerships and establish a better
framework for approaching scientific
questions
vivian thank you for opening up the path
that many continue to follow
we do so because women and men all over
the world will be better for it
and the next two days will help in that
pursuit
now as i finish i would be remiss if i
did not express my sincere appreciation
to our gold sponsors hologic and amgen
and to our silver sponsor my event
and to all our sponsors that understand
the critical nature of this topic
and for making these two days possible
so thank you all very very much and
janine i hand the baton back to you
thank you dr freyr for those lovely
remarks and i too agree vivian is indeed
a force it's now my pleasure to
introduce dr francis collins
dr collins presence and participation
here today are a tribute to the
importance of women's health research as
well as to dr penn and her tremendous
contributions to improving women's
health as i've said before dr collins is
a giant among giants of biomedical
research both as a scientist and as a
leader
many of you know his historical
background but i'll highlight just a few
as a biomedical researcher dr collins
need
his area of concentration
and has
noted for his groundbreaking discoveries
of disease-causing genes and latest
later his leadership of the human genome
project
the latter came to a spectacular
conclusion in 2003 with the completion
of the finished sequence of the human
genome
dr collins has received many awards
including the presidential medal of
freedom the national medical of science
and he is also the 50th winner of the
templeton prize which celebrates
scientific and spiritual curiosity
under his leadership of nra nih there
has been substantial growth in the
research of on women's health
here at nih and from maternal health to
breast cancer and cardiovascular disease
and even mental health
dr collins has also been a champion of
policies that have helped advance the
health of women and it's been my
privilege and honor to partner with him
in the development of the nih policy on
the sex on sex as a biological variable
or we as we call sabv
he's also been a champion for greater
representation of women and
underrepresented groups in the
biomedical workforce
ladies and gentlemen it's my pleasure my
pleasure to introduce the 16th director
of the national institutes of health dr
francis s collins
thank you janine
and
hello to everyone
apologies that there might have been a
slight bit of scary moment here in terms
of uh trying to get me uh linked up uh
just for the last 30 seconds it seems to
work although i'm not sure
my um
is coming through
i keep getting asked whether i will
share my webcam and the answer is yes
there
hello
so um welcome everybody
a slightly frantic arrival here on my
part uh to the fifth annual vivian pin
symposium
and uh of course a lot of teamwork
involved in this in terms of
collaboration between orwh
and fnih in organizing this and of
course aiming for a high bar because the
namesake
dr vivian pin the first permanent nih
associate director for research on
women's health
herself set a very high bar both for her
career and for the way in which she led
orwh
from its initial stages
prior to coming to orwh she was the
first african-american woman to chair an
academic pathology department in the us
and nih vivian worked tirelessly to
improve inclusion
and helped create a broader
understanding of women's health which
moved beyond just the focus on the
reproductive system to accompany
encompass every part of the body right
down to individual cells and a lot has
been happening about that
vivian also established the program
building interdisciplinary research
careers in women's health or birc wh
which i've always pronounced birch and i
hope that's not too far off
and it was my great privilege to work
with vivian as a colleague since i've
now been at nih since oh my gosh 1993
uh to see the way in which her
leadership helped propel the study of
sex and gender and biomedical research
so we gather here for these two days uh
to reflect on how far we have come and
also how far we still need to go i think
it's fair to say that the increased
inclusion of sex and gender and
biomedicine
promises to reap many rewards in terms
of public health and medical care
i would like to reflect for a minute for
instance on the program all of us uh the
largest effort that nih has mounted in a
very long time to recruit a diverse
cohort of individuals uh aiming for one
million participants by the time
recruitment is completed we're up right
now to about three hundred thousand
and this is to
identify by asking these individuals to
serve as our partners uh sharing lots of
information about themselves uh and
sharing their electronic health records
uh providing blood samples for various
measurements including complete dna
sequencing
and this will be the most diverse cohort
that we've ever tried to mount uh
slightly over 50 percent individuals of
racial and ethnic minorities and of
course with a heavy emphasis on a good
balance of sex and gender
that is already coming along in a pretty
exciting way
if i was going to pick something most
recently that perhaps reflects the way
in which a focus on sex and gender is
turning up with observations that people
might not have expected i want to point
to the common fund project called gtex
which stands for genotype tissue
expression basically looking at the
level of rna expressed in a variety of
tissues
44 of them
in almost a thousand individuals done at
rapid autopsy and asking the question
okay which tissues express which genes
that tells you a lot about development
about normal physiology but which of
those differ between men and women
if your idea was you would only find
those differences in the reproductive
system well think again
13 000 genes are expressed differently
between the sexes that's a significant
fraction of the total
and that relates to over 50 bodily
traits and functions very exciting
finding there that tells us a lot that
we didn't know
about the way in which sex and gender
affect
physiological and genetic
contributions so much more to come
traditionally as we all know uh research
had tended to focus on male subjects
and while we made a lot of progress on
that uh going back to the women's health
initiative and the efforts
inspired by members of congress and by
leadership of nih like dr pin and dr
healy is the person that hired me to
come to nih in 1993.
but it wasn't complete in the degree
that you would like and we particularly
were concerned uh janine clayton and i
were
that it did not seem that this notion of
inclusion of both sexes was necessarily
being applied
in other studies like animal research
and so we developed five years ago what
is
affection i hope called the sabv sex is
a biological variable a program and
insisted that nih grantees as they
approach problems needed to consider
this
as a high priority for the research they
were doing so that we would not miss
the fact that differences do occur
between the sexes
we can see uh positive effects on that
as the first
round of grants that were brought
forward under this policy are now
starting to publish their findings
and i've heard many stories from
researchers who were initially a little
skeptical and maybe even a little bit
worried that this was going to put an
additional burden on them in terms of
how they designed their studies they are
waking up to the fact that they're now
beginning to make discoveries about sex
differences that were missed all along
so i think that has been a very
significant step forward and much credit
uh to dr clayton for having the vision
and i was delighted to work with her on
that to get this out there and to get
the community uh to see the value of it
and to embrace it
so um orwh
not only uh playing that role but also
funding some of this research and
helping train the next generation
college 19 pandemic has of course in
involved
all of us in ways we didn't expect for
the last 16 months so i can't come to
this particular discussion without
mentioning that it has been a consuming
passion for me i'm talking to you from
my home office where i've kind of been a
hermit uh for the last year not trying
to manage the nih leadership role in
this way
and it's been amazing how people have
rolled up their sleeves and come forward
with all kinds of creative ideas and
willingness to work prodigiously hard
to advance our efforts and diagnostics
therapeutics and vaccines and we have
made great progress there
i should mention though that we've also
in the area of understanding sex
differences i've been able to appreciate
and even begin to understand a little
bit
that there are
differences in terms of how covet 19 has
affected individuals
certainly when it comes to the severe
form of coca-19 it seems that men and
women are roughly equally affected but
the men have a higher likelihood of the
most severe form in the form and leading
on to death and that is
potentially something that we could
understand a bit on the basis of
comorbidities but not entirely
we are also very troubled now about
noting that there is for this
respiratory virus not only the threat of
severe acute illness which has sadly
taken the lives already of 580 000
people in the united states but there is
this long tail
of consequences where somewhere between
10
and maybe as many as 30 of individuals
do not come back to normal functioning
after a couple of weeks the way you
would expect for other respiratory
viruses
now some of those are people who are in
the icu and perhaps even on a ventilator
and we know post icu syndrome can linger
a long time but some of these are people
who are not as sick as that maybe not
even hospitalized
and yet who weeks or months afterwards
are still suffering from fatigue
shortness of breath
palpitations brain fog making it hard
for them to do hard work that requires
concentration
we have named this pasc or post acute
sequelae of covet 19 but most of the
world is calling it long covid and
that's a fine description as well and we
at nih thanks to additional funds from
the congress are now invested in trying
to understand this by creating and
following a meta cohort of tens of
thousands of individuals who are covet
survivors to try to understand what are
the factors that lead to this what's the
mechanism where these symptoms persist
is there somewhere a reservoir a virus
that hasn't been cleared is this the
immune system that has gone out of whack
and has not come back to where it should
be is this a metabolic issue is this a
blood clotting issue uh we don't really
have good answers and we came to find
them out
but it is certainly the case when you
look at the epidemiology that women
are more likely than men to suffer from
long covid that's another clue that we
need to try to understand and get our
heads around we just had a week ago
a very intense many hour hearing in
front of the house energy and commerce
health subcommittee about long covered
with 50 members of congress asking
probing questions expressing their
concern about this
and giving nih the mandate and trusting
us to come up with answers to try to
sort this out so this is going to be a
big
focus one more surprise and not a happy
one that covered 19 has brought us but
we as the largest supporter of
biomedical research in the world are
determined to take that on
so nih called upon in that space
certainly with diagnostics we worked
really hard to come up with new
platforms to make it possible for people
to find out if they have the virus
including home testing which is
currently undergoing a pilot in north
carolina and in tennessee
that is going to teach us whether this
is a way in which we can reduce
transmission and give people the ability
in their own hands to be able to find
out whether they're carrying the virus
and i would suspect from many other
things that we've known that it often be
women in the household who figure out
how to make the most of that kind of
opportunity
so i guess um just to conclude my brief
remarks here i'm really glad we're going
to have this opportunity at this uh
symposium the fifth annual of even pin
symposium
to contemplate the areas where sex and
gender are critical in biomedical
research
for covert 19 and of course for many
other things as well and i wish you all
the best as you take the
time here virtual though it is
to hear presentations and to engage in
panel discussions figure out what more
we should be doing that we haven't
thought of yet
we want to be as creative as possible in
tackling this very important mandate
that we have
so with that i am going to say thank you
for the chance to say these few remarks
and then move into my opportunity
to introduce the next presenter who i
understand will be coming to you by
video in a moment
and that is a member of congress
representative madeleine dean
uh from pennsylvania um and madeline
dean is a mother a grandmother an
attorney a professor
and a former four-term member of the
pennsylvania house of representatives
now currently in her second term in the
u.s congress where she represents the
fourth district of pennsylvania that
would be berks and montgomery counties
if you know pennsylvania
she serves on the financial services
committee
the steering and policy committee she's
vice chair of the judiciary committee
and particularly appropriate for today's
discussion she is co-chair of the
bipartisan women's caucus
she has championed progressive
priorities like public education
combating addiction equal rights access
to health care protecting the
environment ethics criminal justice
reform stopping gun violence and more
she's been a very busy person and so it
is a real pleasure to be able to
introduce her and to give her the
opportunity to speak uh to all of you
from her perspective
as a member of congress about this issue
of integrating sex and gender into
biomedical research as a path for better
science and innovation
congresswoman theme
of the symposium the office of research
on women's health and the foundation for
the national institutes of health for
asking me to participate and offer
keynote remarks for this the fifth
annual vivian pin symposium
thank you to dr janine clayton and dr
francis collins for your leadership
especially this past year and i
especially thank dr vivian pin for all
your work to improve health and career
opportunities for women and minorities
and particularly for the work you have
done to ensure that federally funded
medical studies include female patients
it is my pleasure to be here and
highlight the importance of supporting
research that advances science and
research for the health of women
especially during national women's
health week we know the past year has
been like
unlike any other and has highlighted the
many disparities we see in women's
health
to have equitable representation we need
women and minorities in every field and
at every table in health care especially
representation matters for trust and
quality of care
i am a co-chair of the bipartisan
women's caucus it is a priority of ours
to address the needs of women and
families
examining sex and gender in biomedical
research is necessary to understand the
numerous ways sex and gender can affect
and influence health outcomes
in the past decade we know there have
been improvements to include sex as a
biological variable variable but we know
more needs to be done
the pandemic has demonstrated the need
for accurate research that looks at sex
as a biological variable for example
data suggests there are stark
disparities based on sex regarding the
effects of copenhagen
covert 19 appears to be infecting
similar numbers of women and men but men
tend to face higher mortality rates and
women seem to seem more likely to be
diagnosed with covet 19 long haulers
patients who face serious long-term side
effects following the initial infection
one study suggests women outnumber men
four to one within the long-haul
population with increased information as
to the adverse effects of long-haulers
women have reported feeling hesitant to
talk to their healthcare providers due
to a fear of being dismissed
covet 19 has only exacerbated health
impacts on a female population that
already faces stigma and unique
challenges navigating the healthcare
system
with all of this covet has economically
affected women especially women of color
more so than other populations recent
reports have announced that 25 of women
say they are fiscally worse off a year
into the pandemic compared with 18 of
men
we know women make up the majority of
essential workers in service industries
and elsewhere and also tend to do much
of the unpaid caregiving and domestic
work
women are disproportionately dealing
with the impacts of worsening mental
health and women especially women of
color are more likely than men to live
in poverty placing them at increased
risk for food insecurity
if we can use sex and gender in research
we can better understand how covet 19
will impact not only health outcomes but
economic and social outcomes as well
highlighting sex and gender in
biomedical research may provide us with
better predictive tools to understand
how future diseases or future infections
will impact women help with this issue i
was pleased to lead an appropriations
letter alongside my co-chair of the
bipartisan women's caucus congresswoman
jennifer gonzalez cologne along with our
vice chair congresswoman lucy mcbath
that requests language to highlight the
importance of studying how sex as a
biological variable can impact short and
long-term health health effects due to
infections with covet 19.
research intersex as a biological
variable can impact
beyond covet 19 it can lead to greater
understanding of health outcomes for
women's health with regard to maternal
health
mental health and addiction this
research can be transformative for women
of all backgrounds and all health issues
or crises
thank you again for inviting me to
provide remarks for this very important
symposium i am excited for the
conversations and discussions you all
will have and hear the ways we can
continue to improve and address barriers
that currently exist in our research
again thank you for the honor of being
invited to speak with you
thank you very much congresswoman
madeline dean we are so thrilled to be
able to include you in our program today
and as you said women
belong in every field and at every table
and you mentioned how transformative
research can be
to improving the lives of all women so
we certainly appreciate you being with
us today
next i'd like to introduce miss jamie
white orwh's health science strategy and
relations lead uh to kick us off with
some introductory
um instructions and housekeeping items
jamie
i thank you dr clayton i appreciate that
i would like to thank all of the
sponsors for this meeting but also want
to thank fnih for their partnership in
this i also want to thank dr clayton for
the the wonderful end of introduction
and also setting the stage for this so
we can go to the next slide by any
chance
so while we're here the objective for
this meeting is to illustrate the
scientific societal and economic
opportunities of integrating sex and
gender into the biomedical research and
the power of us synergistically doing
this together the goals are creating
bridges and capacity to work
bi-directionally across silos because we
unfortunately are in silos within the
scientific enterprise and to build a
resilient interconnected network which i
hope that we've done today
this will include federal and private
funders of research industry and
business journal editors and publishers
professional societies scientific and
health organizations health career
health care providers researchers
academic institutions policy makers and
also the public we hope to develop
strategies with the help with you to
achieve the integration of sex and
gender considerations throughout the
biomedical research enterprise and
lastly we help to characterize issues
related to the health of women while
exploring women's health research
priorities and public health
opportunities
for a multi-dimensional perspective to
advance the integration of section
gender considerations via
transdisciplinary cross-sector
approaches and partnerships so i just
want to do a quick overview of what's to
come so we hit the next slide
so in advance um i want to again thank
dr clayton for setting the stage dr um
fryer for opening remarks and also dr
collins for open remarks and our keynote
address um we will have a panel right
after this and the um called teach one
reach one academia's roll call and that
will actually still be in the auditorium
then you guys will have a break you get
to eat
then after that we will have another
panel that will be hosted back in the
auditorium um called moving beyond
inclusion to innovation the scientific
opportunity and there will be a one more
panel before you have a small break
which is the life cycle of communicating
the science
after a break um we will ask you all to
go to the breakout rooms and in case you
haven't are not from there if you look
at the bottom of your um
of the scroll bar there's a place that
says
breakout rooms please go there and or if
you go to the lobby that's also on the
screen in there and if you have any
troubles with navigation please look at
the navigation on video because i will
also give you information to help you
all to navigate throughout the different
parts of the environment
after the breakout sessions then we will
have our last final panel of the day
which will be backed by public demand
and then i'll do a wrap-up in closing
and then that will allow you guys to
have a small break and then we will ask
you all to join us
for the evening firestar check with dr
pin and america's doctor dr fauci
that will actually be hosted in the
network lounge where you also have
opportunity to chat but lastly um there
will be a live q a with me and dr
dr penn so please stay tuned in that and
so for the next stage just quickly
next slides are
the next day you'll see me again i'll be
doing a welcoming recap of today um then
there will be a panel for government
agencies call to action we'll be doing
another panel called putting skin in the
game the economic opportunity and then
there will be a lunch break
after the break for 45 minutes we'll
join back here again all of these um all
the panels will be hosted in the
auditorium so i just want to reflect
that and make sure everyone knows that
and that will be the society's promise
for improved science cultures a
scientific opportunity and then we will
have you guys join us back into the
breakout rooms for breakout session two
that's entitled the scientific
enterprise
the last panel of the day will be
creating synergistic partnerships the
power of working together one of our
themes and one of the major parts of
while we're here
well after that we'll have a small break
and then there will be report out so you
can actually hear and learn what
happened in the other breakout sessions
i want to just reflect that for the
breakouts we're asking for the first day
that you please join based on the
affiliation that you are as far as your
job or career
um and then for the second day whatever
close your boat whatever you feel that
you want to join into and hear and
listen into please feel free to join
that web webinar or that link um on the
next day so if you have any questions
obviously please go throughout the
health desk because that is also there
to help anyone that needs anything
and
on that note i'm going to turn it back
over again enjoy the meeting i hope you
all enjoy it i hope you guys could
return it and i'm grateful that you all
are here so with that i'm going to end
and say thanks